as winter hits the picture in hospitals
across the country is the same a health
service in crisis delays in any worse
than ever before a severe shortage of
beds and the number of people waiting
for routine treatment has grown to over
4 million a grim reminder of the media
challenge facing the prime minister as
he pledges to fix the NHS Peter Burke
and his son James bore the brunt of this
surge in demand James who has a learning
disability had to wait almost eight
hours for an ambulance last month after
his catheter come out leaving him in
lots of pain and covered in blood we
just didn't know what had gone on we
didn't know whether the catheter had
moved inside he had ripped him inside
and we just we just hadn't got clue he
was you know I can't describe how I was
feeling
I was so scared what was going to happen
with him South East Coast ambulance
service apologized for the delay and
said staff were in contact to check on
James's condition they pointed to an
8.5% increase in call-outs compared to
last year this overwhelming demand on
health services highlighted in the
latest NHS figures which showed just
eighty 1.4 percent of any patients were
seen within four hours in November the
target is 95 percent almost 90,000
patients waited more than four hours to
be admitted to hospital compared with
just over 54,000 in the same month last
year of these around 1000 patients had
to wait more than 12 hours last year
that number was 258 a rise of over 300
percent
what we've got to see is some real focus
on getting to the heart of the
challenges in the NHS so this is about
how do we tackle demand we know that
many more people are coming through the
door and they are sicker the
Conservative government has promised a
big cash boost for the NHS 50,000 more
nurses and to bring back for nursing
bursaries axed on a Theresa May but some
question how much impact this will have
we really need our politicians to
deliver on the promise
they're making I don't think it's going
to be a quick fix however this is going
to take a long time to make better and I
think promises which imply that it will
be a quick fix are unrealistic frontline
staff in the NHS they're working harder
than ever to see more people but
performance continues to fall and with
the full toll of winter yet to come the
pressure on services is only going to
get worse Charlotte Lomas Sky News